turning now to the covid pandemic as
early as today the cdc is expected to
relax some of its covid19 restrictions
including those for kids going back to
school in the fall nancy chan is here
with more nancy good news for a lot of
parents here what are we learning good
morning to you tony cbs news has
obtained a draft report on the
guidelines that could be coming today
they are likely to involve two key areas
for students kova testing and social
distancing and they'd be coming just as
children across the country are getting
ready to head back to school
the cdc is planning to simplify and
streamline a wide number of its covet 19
recommendations
starting in the classroom
according to a draft document obtained
by cbs news the changes could allow
schools to relax their strict social
distancing measures which have already
been effectively phased out by the cdc
they would also de-emphasize so-called
test to stay strategies where students
exposed to the virus take regular tests
to stay in the classroom so the test to
stay strategies we've turned over a lot
of infections that were asymptomatic and
forced kids out of the classroom i think
they can lift those things at this point
and that seems to be where cdc is
heading school superintendent michael
cornell fully supports the possible
changes what we have to focus on in
school is making sure our kids
experience joy value and connection in
school
another potential update those exposed
to covid would no longer need to
quarantine vaccinated or not
instead the recommendation would be to
mask for 10 days and test five days
after exposure still the proposed
changes are raising some concerns with
only about 30 percent of younger
children fully vaccinated and more than
80 percent of americans living in areas
with medium to high covert rates dr
scott gottlieb says the cdc would still
ask schools to remain vigilant for
example notifying parents when there's a
closed contact so parents can keep an
eye on their children and get them
tested
and part of the cdc's reasoning in
lifting the quarantine recommendation
for anyone exposed to the virus is the
increase in people who now have coven-19
antibodies they also want to limit the
social and economic impact that
quarantines are having on the nation and
there's also this aspect that with
simpler and more streamlined rules
people will fall follow them a little
bit better too yeah we've got the
antibodies we've got vaccines we've got
other treatments uh kids need to be in
school and as the that one expert said
they need that love that connection that
learning and if this can help them get
it i'm all for it and we've been talking
about getting to this place for quite
some time totally been in this fight
seems like finally we're putting the
gloves down yeah we're getting yeah but
we're still getting getting co-ed yeah
but it's just not as extreme yeah
hearing the words de-emphasize is a good
thing
kids need to be in school they do fancy
i agree with that